wait just like they do it on all of the
Beauty reality shows
look how naturally beautiful that landed
no hey guys guys help make sure you did
what I literally look like back from
back to the future I got shocked okay
let's be normal so no one interesting
ever you're welcome oh this looks like
Jersey Shore Little Mermaid no no you
know your life is different now
I used to vlog every Friday I had a
thing called fried diary if you guys
remember it leave comments down below
because it was really fun to do I've
just gotten out of practice with it and
so now that mamrie and I that's my dog
it's literally a 1:00 a.m. I don't know
why she's awake this is what goose does
she sleeps for hours and hours and hours
and then as soon as I make any sort of
move to do something that I like
workwise need to do she just you know
inserts herself in a very passive but
aggressive way and I can't say that I am
NOT inspired by it
I'm a very passive-aggressive person I
shouldn't take cues from oh at 1:10 a.m.
is when you decide that you should leave
okay okay great well as my relationship
with my dog if you didn't know mamrie
Hart and I have started a new YouTube
show called this might get which is five
days a week that's what that number
means Monday through Friday on the
YouTube channel youtube.com slash this
might get and so I decided to start
picking up my vlog camera again and
trying to vlog again and here is what
came of that haha going hi guys today's
a very exciting day when I'm vlogging
hey let's see how long this lasts
but - I'm vlogging because of the
special occasion that is happening and
that is that maimry hart and i are
shooting our brand new show this might
get that dr. day for the first time we
have been secretly scheming and planning
a brand new series for you guys called
this might get loosely based off of our
stage show this might get weird and it's
gonna be a five-day week show Monday
through Friday and we're shooting two
episodes today the first true test
episode today and then tomorrow we're
shooting three episodes and then next
week we're shooting five episodes and
I'm so excited it's finally happening
it's gonna be a really fun dumb sort of
talk show variety s kind of thing I'm a
little nervous but excited to finally
get a schedule going so we're on our way
to go shoot the first episode and I'll
show you guys said I'll show you guys
the team that's behind the scenes of the
show you might recognize a lot of them
I'll fix the color correction of this
camera oh hi good morning
9:08 a.m. already greats are supposed to
be there at 9:00 a.m. but it's okay man
was getting her hair and makeup done I'm
coming a little hair makeup ready ish so
it's already a great balance okay we'll
see you guys on the set of this might
get excited not so nervous for some
reason
also just wasn't you guys to see how
much it impacted me for the first day of
shooting casual oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
he's too beautiful
who do we have in here wait where's this
beans here no and never they gonna make
her ate ha yeah hair makeup done gonna
meet our producer you might recognize
her from such productions as camp Takota
and my assistant
Diane Kang you recognize that
[Laughter]
name is getting full beautified hello oh
hello
it could have been better I think it
looks great look at all these pretty
shiny people and our set and all of it
and look at this Oh things have already
gone down that shouldn't have gone down
but our crew is the biggest best sports
of all time oh my god stress sweating
and shaking we finished one episode and
she on that couch oh yeah the show isn't
just hosted by memory night we did it we
wrapped our first day of shooting this
might get and I am watching Bravo
reality television and eating chips I
wouldn't have it any other way
tomorrow we're shooting two more
episodes Oh doing that here let me just
case you're wondering because a tiny cow
in that room that is chewing on a bone
bigger she's busy she's in a meeting
hustle hustle hustle I'll flog again
when I have remembered a vlog again see
you in the next clip ha oh boy not the
time of day to be shooting no in the
face to be shooting good morning it is
Wednesday February a date 8:30 a.m. just
showered and wash my hair cuz I washed
it last night
Oh unnecessary information for you we
are getting ready to go back to set
today for more this might get we have
two episodes of shooting today
they went really well yesterday and
today we're working with drones
something most people my age end or just
people involved in tech know how to do
and how to operate how to put together
but something mamrie and I have never
touched and thought it'd be funny to
just try and figure it out on camera
that should be fun um I never get PR
packages from any makeup company or
beauty or anything like that
other than poo pourri shout out to poo
pourri thank you you're the only ones
that believe in me as a beauty guru on
YouTube and now go to 7-eleven 7-eleven
sent me a bunch of their beauty products
that I couldn't find at my local
7-eleven when I did my 7-eleven make up
things a thank you they also sent me
some flexible flats and a corkscrew
bottle opener so they really know my
brand so thank you lots of other YouTube
lifestyle gurus like myself get a lot of
pure packages from liked art and NARS
and Mac and I'm getting poo pourri in
7/11 you know what I could be happier
let's get ready and go to stay take two
onset twins and bow so yeah so we got a
little beans in the mix she's our bully
oh my god we don't know what's for it
but we're ready to play play this coming
in hot
[Music]
I mean this is the most practical
purchase I've ever made in my entire
life they meant the videos that this
jumpsuit has been in is unreal
[Music]
this is a business meeting
okay
hi we're back from shooting today I was
just about to throw out this box now
remember this morning I told you about
all that sweet sweet 7-eleven PR beauty
stuff from and I realized that there was
more in the box than what I had
originally thought I almost threw away
can you imagine
Kiki's God this is why I'm not holding
the camp is marshmallow lollipop that is
a cat love school another marshmallow
lollipop that's a unicorn hey Lilly
Singh shoutout you don't need a
shout-out hi Lily
and then this Yuri is Reacher this is a
mermaid mer person where person I don't
know it's edible oh it's only 110
calories cute and then also just some
chocolate-covered strawberry sandwich
cookies with cream filling everything's
it yeah - make it all make sense
if I look I know I've been terrible at
vlogging if this is what we're calling
this right now today's launch day of
this might get it's very very exciting
this morning mamrie and I went to do
Kaitlyn Bristowe
I'm so bad with names let alone last day
and she was one of the bachelorettes and
she's got a podcast and we went into
that this morning and they asked us if
we wanted a car service and we thought
or we knew that we're gonna have like
wine or champagne mimosas on the podcast
we were like of course yeah that sounds
great and this is what we got
[Music]
picking up memory right now yeah coming
together yes but now it's Monday night
and I am setting up to do a cooking
video I want to do a cooking video and
the reason that I remembered to vlog is
because something so fun just my lights
over my stove were busted one of them
was busted and so I was like Oh domestic
goddess at your service I'll fix it
and I went to try and fix it and the old
light bulb was greased in there so much
it was stuck that when I pulled it out i
electrocuted myself and I could [ __ ] my
hands so I'm not gonna touch the light
system but that shocked me into the
realisation law that I hadn't logged
about today also if you are attempting
any electrical work in your own domicile
regardless of skill level don't
is there a Diane Kang New Year is there
a Diane Kang Hey
hi Dan King can I give this to you and
now here we are it is 1:15 a.m. Tuesday
night and I can't tell you how excited
and proud and just like I'm a British
descent so it feels weird to feel
hopeful about something that you care
about so this show that I have with me
right now I feel really good about and I
just want you guys to go watch it so
click the link in my description if you
haven't subscribed or looked at it at
all yet it's really really super fun cuz
lit a new fire under my ass hole that
makes me feel just like very inspired
very creative very excited I think goose
left because she wanted me to have this
singular moment with you guys she's very
very considerate in that way I just
constantly toe the line between looking
like Fabio and then like like a Danish
Kmart model and then also kind of myself
I don't I don't know that I don't know
also Becca being the new bachelorette
that's like literally let's take a wound
and then just like pour soy sauce in it
and see what happens